[Applause]
hi good folks i am john and i'd like to
welcome you to the dr
john dalone show this is a collar driven
show we will talk about your
relationships your life your parents
your mental health
your weird neighbor conspiracy theory
anything
and everything right the world has gone
and lost its mind
and we're all defining our communities
by who we hate together
instead of what we're for right people
are struggling with their mental health
divorce rates are up across the world
people are out of work divided
things are just generally a mess and i'm
here to help
i'm here to walk with you and provide
you with wisdom wisdom from emerging
science and research
and experience as well as ancient wisdom
and truth and insights that we've just
forgotten in route to becoming faster
and bigger and more arrogant and more
impressed and satisfied with ourselves
and look around at that what that's got
us right
we can all feel that we've entered into
this season of transition and i'm here
to walk with you so give me a call
at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
you can also email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
leave your number tell me what's going
on and we will get back in touch with
you
so my hope is that you're asking
yourself why does the world need another
new podcast
for god's sakes there's like a billion
of them right and who is this delony
dude
he has no fancy books he's co-hosted the
dave ramsey show with dave a few times
and now he's fancy-pants enough to get
his own uh
podcast is he shooting this from his
mom's basement like what's the deal
so here's who i am for the past two
decades
i've walked alongside countless people
during their most challenging
and darkest moments i've been there i've
actually done the stuff
i've sat with people in the aftermath of
destructive life choices
i've held mothers and fathers after
losing a child or a loved one
and i've walked alongside both young and
old folks crushed by heartbreak and loss
anxiety depression and other mental
health challenges
i've officiated both funerals and
weddings and i've seen both love
and heartbreak and along the way i've
wrestled with my own mental health and
relationship demons
i've earned two phds and i've spoken and
studied with folks from across the
country
from harvard to tiny little faith-based
universities in the southern united
states
i've partnered with parents families
businesses
anyone you could imagine employees to
senior leaders
to help everybody live lives of dignity
joy and purpose and here's the deal
through it all
i'm an eternal optimist i believe
there's joy
meaning relationships laughter all of it
on the other side of disconnection
mental illness
and pain that's why we're starting this
podcast it's a color-driven show
about you where you can call and get
real answers
real truths to the stuff going on in
your life so give me a call it's
1-844-693-3291
let's go straight to the phone jessica
how are you
hi john i'm good how are you outstanding
good morning how can i help
good morning um so i've been dealing
with
some issues in my marriage regarding
infidelity
um i've been married for 10 years and we
have
two kids and i just don't i saw your
post the other day about
mercy and forgiveness and i was just
you know wanting to get some guidance on
like
when to keep giving mercy and
forgiveness or when
you know is it enough so tell me about
your the history of your marriage 10
years
tell me about it yeah so i mean um
everything you know we've
it's everything was pretty much okay and
i was like you know happy we just had a
child last year and
our second baby and i thought my family
was complete and everything but
um i went out of town with the kids and
came back and found out that he had been
um you know going out and partying and
seeing other women
and i'm just you know struggling with
this a lot so is this
is this recent has been going on for the
arc of the decade you all have been
together
so that you know i just found that out
recently but um when he came clean about
everything he did
say that he had been with at least you
know
three women during the ten years of
marriage
[Music]
and um so we were working things out i
forgave him and i
was trying to work things out with him
but um a couple months ago i just
found some emails where he had gone to
meet up with a prostitute
so i was kind of just shaken by that and
i'm not sure if i'm able to
continue with him or not so what do you
want to do
i feel like i'm ready to move on
and when you say ready i feel like i'm
ready to move on that sends
pretty benign finding out that somebody
after a decade has been cheating on you
hiring prostitutes um yeah tell me how
you feel
i feel well at first i was really ready
to forgive you know i thought it was
just like
you know we've been together for a long
time we got married young
um but he kind of i don't know i guess
his attitude about it like
the days where i didn't feel good i felt
like he didn't give me like
you know a shoulder to cry on or like
listen or with compassion you know
well a compassionate person isn't gonna
have serial affairs
and call prostitutes right so somebody
who cares about your feelings isn't
gonna do that
um so i wouldn't expect that in your
moment of need and crisis that
suddenly this person's gonna show up and
be the knight in shining armor that you
thought he was for the last decade
um how old are your kids
well the youngest one is only one year
old and the other one's a first grader
yeah so you're in it up to your eyeballs
already right
yeah i mean like i said everything
seemed okay i thought you know our
family was complete you know
it just kind of came as a shock to me
that it came at this time in my life
whenever everything was good like
had it been at a time when we weren't so
good like i could understand but
so what what what can i help you with
well i guess i mean he's you know of
course asking for forgiveness and
you know i just
don't know if i should keep giving
forgiveness at this point
so forgiveness and tolerating
unhealthy unsafe behavior are two
totally different things
and so i'm a huge proponent of
forgiveness i'm
a forgiveness is baggage that we carry
around
other people hurt us right it's like
punching yourself in the nose
and hoping somebody else will bleed
when you don't forgive somebody it's
just it's just a waste of your own
energy
but that doesn't mean that you allow
yourself to repeatedly get
bit by the same rattlesnake right that
you keep sticking your hand back in the
bag hoping the snake won't bite you
again
it's gonna bite you it's shown it's
gonna bite you and it's told you i'm
gonna bite you it's demonstrated over
and over this is what i do
and so i'll forgive the snake the snake
is what it is i'm going to stop but i'm
not putting my hand in the bag
and i'm going to tie the bag off i'm
going to give it to somebody else
because i'm going to quit carrying that
bag around
and so forgiveness mercy those are
different than continually letting
yourself get kicked
right and here's the other thing
one of the most damaging moments of this
besides the betrayal coming from
your husband right that sense of just
utter what do i do now i've got this
perfect little family and all of a
sudden it is not what i thought
is this frightening scary moment
where you jessica no longer trust
jessica
because jessica thought everything was
good and jessica
thought i had a great little family with
its own little ups and downs but the
things were great
and you've lost trust in yourself and
these are really critical moments when
you've got to have people around you
that can help you see clearly
and help you plot out what the next
point's going to be because it's not as
simple as just saying you know what i'm
through
i'm moving out tomorrow if you don't
have a place to move if you have a
if you're a stay-at-home mom and you've
got a kid that you're homeschooling in
first grade
and or half quarantined schooling or
whatever and you've got a one-year-old
still toddling around the house
it's not so easy so you're gonna have to
get some folks to walk alongside you
are you convinced that the marriage is
over
i mean i i see like
you know the man that he is that you
know takes care of his responsibilities
and his family and loves us and cares
about us
hold on hold on he is that's not a man
who's going to be hiring prostitutes
and his wife is not taking care of his
responsibilities
he says that he considers it progress
that he didn't actually
he says he got there and he was there
but then he felt bad and left and didn't
do anything but i mean obviously i don't
have any proof that he didn't do
anything
nonsense nonsense he says that that's
progress that he's
trying to get better nope
i'm going to 100 disagree with that and
you can give him the number to the show
and tell him to call me
um no absolutely zero percent progress
to call a prostitute and just go hang
out in a hotel and just be like hey
what's up
i'm just this is part of my halfway
house i just call prostitutes pay them
for their time
and we play cards and then i go home
that's not progress
progress would be coming to you on hands
and knees saying i have failed you
i've failed our kids i've failed our
marriage
i've broken the vows that i swore betw
before
our friends and our family and our
community and if
if we're people of faith be behind or in
front of whatever deity we we pledged
ourselves against
and this will never happen again and
here's my credit cards so i'm not going
to be stupid
um here's the number to a marriage
therapist here's the number to our
financial advisor
here's all the credit card statements
that's what
like submission looks like that's what
humility that's what i screwed up real
real
bad and i'm gonna do everything i can to
make it right that's progress
nonsense progress i'm only i didn't
inhale
you know the cheese louise you're going
to get me all fired up and it's the
morning here
jessica so here's the deal um not
progress i'm never going to be in a
position where i'm going to tell
somebody this marriage is over
if somebody's not safe that's going to
be a call that you're gonna have to make
i will tell you that um somebody who
is does not come back from doing
something stupid from having
an affair and is not utterly repentant
on their hands and face
ready to um partner with you and a
professional therapist or a pastor
a couple of of married couples in your
lives that you know well
that you trust and is not
ready to turn over everything and be
totally clear and transparent
i'm not buying it i'm not buying it
somebody's good that's not going to let
you have
really hard days and pick up the slack
with the kids
that's not going to give you a shoulder
to cry on is it going to let you
leave the house for some time because
you're going to have to reorient
yourself to a new marriage
to a new partner to a new you because
you don't trust yourself anymore
man that's just the wrong attitude all
the way across the board
and somebody who's been a serial cheater
over the course of a decade who's seeing
prostitutes you see him prostitutes in
the middle of covet for god's sake
we're not supposed to even go outside
right we like meeting a prostitute in a
hotel with a mask on god almighty dude
yeah i'm not buying it um i'm not gonna
be the one that tells you to pull the
trigger that's gonna be decision you
make
i'm gonna tell you that i'm not seeing
any sort of repentant behavior any sort
of you know what i was wrong let's make
this different let's change
um it sounds like he doesn't think
you're gonna do anything
and i want to also publicly acknowledge
women in these in these awful situations
because there's economic um
ramifications to just walking out the
door right
it sounds all cool to say i'm marching
right but you have a one-year-old and a
first grader
and you've got to think about rent and
you've got to think about food and
you've got to think about
child care and all of those things
take wisdom all those things take
careful careful planning
and so please get with somebody today
get with somebody that you trust
that you can be vulnerable with um have
them go to an attorney with you if that
ends up being your next step
have them sit down with your husband um
if you
decide you want to have further
conversations but
i'm progress nonsense man nonsense
1-844-693-3291 dude you call me progress
god almighty oh my
lee dude it's gonna be a great morning
and i'm all fired up here
um that
that leads me to this i got somebody
sent me this this morning
and it i'm gonna show this up to the
camera
it's a one of these pinteresty um
instagrammy why i crossfit
i being like the letter i because
everything's cool since it's like an
iphone
um why i crossfit
geez you take a cult and then you make
the cult hipster by putting an eye in
front of it that's just ridiculous
here's what it says because i can go
when you can't go any further
because easy will no longer suffice
because i just don't get better
i get better than great and strive for
perfection what does that even mean
because i know my limits and defy them
daily
because i don't stop when i'm tired when
i'm tired i stop when i'm
done when i'm done i can't even see us
in a straight face
because i know pain is weakness leaving
the body
leaving the body or pain is just a
signal your body tells you that crap's
breaking but whatever dude
because i have what it takes even if it
takes all that i've got
i don't even know what that means here's
my favorite because i don't use
because i don't use machines i have
become one
nope you haven't dude you're just a
person here's the thing
i hate i hate analogies that just
that describe people like machines like
um
dude i'm just letting off some steam or
i got my wires crossed like you're a
person man
you're a person yes i think people quit
too soon
i think that most people go through life
um
not finding out what they're made of i
think people are not intentional with
their days
and i don't think i think a lot of
people don't set goals and they don't go
through the hard hard things to solve
them
but this kind of nonsense makes the
author look goofy
and makes why i crossfit i being why i
have my iphone
in my ipad and i crossfit because i'm
greater than my obstacles you know what
that may be the
the only grain of truth here we are
greater than our obstacles when
you work hard and you have a community
around you but also
pain is a signal man pain is a signal
that you need to get in better shape
pain is a signal that maybe i need to
take a day off and rest maybe i need to
have a gratitude journal maybe i need to
get with community
with people and for god's sake stop
referring to yourself as a machine
you're not a machine
you're a person we are not
machines to fill oil into and to fix the
gaskets bro
we are people that need to love that
need to have goals need to have
community
and they need to work together stumbling
and bumbling and sometimes sprinting and
sometimes
resting towards wherever it is we're
headed as
a community jessica you got me fired up
all right let's go back to the phones
let's go to stephanie in richmond
virginia
stephanie good morning how can i help
hi good morning john thanks for taking
my call thank you for calling
absolutely um so i wanted to call and
get your opinion
um my father um just passed away
i'm so sorry thank you so much um it was
an estranged relationship for about
um 15 years and right now he's survived
by
his father and two brothers and both all
of them have very very bad financial
situations
um so at this point there's really
nobody except for me to
pay for a burial um
and i'm just not sure that i really want
to
and i'm kind of looking for guidance on
how to
how to go about thinking about this and
deciding this wow thank you so much for
the call first
and foremost i'm sorry for your loss uh
even a strange relationships and messy
relationships there's just something
about
when our mom and dad passes away right
that hits us in our guts
why was your relationship estranged so
he and my mother um
got divorced when i was about five years
old and um it was due to alcoholism and
drug use
and then he just never actually um
made it past that and unfortunately
passed away due to those
circumstances um
and all of those elements are present in
the other family members lives as well
so it's really
it's a bad situation with all of them um
and unfortunately my father passed away
from it so
we've spoken maybe three times in the
last
10 years um for just a couple minutes at
a time
so the the way i first before those
let me give you a couple things here i'm
kind of stumbling over my words here a
little bit
first and foremost you've got no
obligation to pay for anything okay
um i want you to there is no rule
there's no hard and fast
um character issues here
if i mean he gave up his right to be a
dad he
left you as when you were five and uh he
spent most of his life in devotion to
drugs and alcohol and other things
and so there is no um
no requirement that you pay for this
right the way i
like to look at these situations is a
saying that i heard years ago and that
has stuck with me
across a number of different issues
which is not by my hand but in my lap
meaning there are a number of things in
my life that i have to deal with
that i didn't cause that aren't my fault
that i
technically don't have a responsibility
to deal with but they are in my lap
um and i didn't um
hit a guy on the side of the road but
he's bleeding he's in the right thing
for me to do right now is to help him up
right the thing that i'm not gonna sleep
tonight unless i don't do it
and so the question you have to ask
yourself is five years from now 10 years
from now 15 years from now
or 30 minutes from now what is who is
stephanie
what is the character of stephanie um
and are you a person that would step in
if somebody at your local church needed
some help to pay for a
funeral um or are you somebody that
would would
pitch in five years from now and help a
brother who's struggling
you just gotta ask yourself that and
what you're gonna be able to sleep with
and not sleep with
um and that that is the character
question
that ends up dictating a lot of my
present day
on uh not i'm angry right now but
who do i want to remember myself as
years from now
so do you have little kids i do
yeah i have um i have a six week old and
a two-year-old
did they ever meet their granddad
my two-year-old did one once
how did that go it was okay
um he
you know wasn't overly involved but he
was happy to see
um and meet my son so what do you want
to do
um i don't
i don't know i think you know i'm open
to
probably paying for something simple and
helping out in that regard
um i just i might be maybe a little
overly pragmatic but it's hard for me to
really see
um what purpose it would serve um
at this point which with him already
being gone it doesn't actually help
the reconciliation there or the
relationship um
but in the same way i don't want to seem
cruel or to
um you know violate my own character and
regret that later
yeah and i think i think thinking about
reconciliation
as a as a two-sided way you're right
he's passed away
what a ceremony can do in the grieving
process even in a painful grieving
process how
again however big small medium size of
ceremony there is
right even if it's a the least expensive
cremation in a tiny
urn that you deal with on your own
this the reconciliation comes from your
side it's
it gives you a process to set the bricks
down
it gives you an opportunity to say you
can't hurt me anymore
you can never hurt my grandkids you
can't abandon me anymore
and in my last moment i took the high
road
i forgive you i'm setting the stuff down
and
i'm gonna be the mother
i'm gonna be the parent i'm gonna love
my kids i'm gonna love my husband
i'm gonna love the people close to me
like you never did
and then you're gonna set that stuff
down and then you're gonna move on and
again
that doesn't mean you have to pay for a
funeral it absolutely doesn't you can do
that with a letter to yourself in an
open field somewhere in nebraska for all
i care
um what i don't want you to do is let
your anger and the short-sightedness
and the it doesn't have an immediate roi
it doesn't solve stuff right now i don't
want that to
pain you five years from now and ten
years from now and you think man for a
thousand bucks
for 500 bucks i don't i don't know how
much uh these things cost anymore
um for 2500 bucks i could have taken the
lead in my family
once again as the only one who's not an
addict is the only one who sticks around
is the only one who does their
commitments
i paid for a dad's small little
get-together i bought the cheese platter
and i got a minister in to say a couple
of nice words
i did the right thing i honored my dad
even when my dad
didn't honor us and then i put those
bricks
down and then i got about the the hard
work
the challenging work of moving forward
right of living into my family
my partner and making sure that we're
all on the same page moving forward so
that's totally up to you there's not a
right or wrong here you don't owe the
man anything
um if i'm in your position i would pay
for it
i would find the money i would pay for
it because it's at this point it's about
my character it's about
the the man i want my kids to see me
be not by my hand but in my lap um
and i'm gonna that's the way i would
handle it stephanie so thank you so much
for the call that's a hard hard one
all right let's go to emails remember
you can email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com millions of you are
already emailing
that's not true at least like 11 of you
have already emailed so far keep them
coming
more than 11 but all right let's go to
jesus jesus writes last december
i was diagnosed with a rare form of
cancer in late stage 3-4
and i was told my survival chance was
below 10
i'm happy to say that i am now
cancer-free i was scanned in july and it
is gone
brother jesus man that's awesome now the
world looks
and feels different and people closest
to me
say that i'm different and i don't feel
that's a bad thing
how do i best communicate to my family
and friends that this is me now
wow so first and foremost man what a
gift that's awesome
i'm glad you're cancer-free and getting
a rare form of cancer diagnosis
that says your survival is less than 10
percent
can really clarify things for you what's
important to you
the things that you loved about your
current life the things about your life
that you wish were very
very different right and then all of a
sudden
brother you get a second chance
i'm just trying to put myself in your
shoes i walk into the doctor with my
head held low
holding the hand of a kid both of my
children holding the hand of my wife
and we walk in and i get to get the
results back of my scan and my doctor
walks in shaking his head
and he's just like deloney you have no
cancer man you are cancer free
i don't know what happened this thing is
gone
and i would just try to imagine the
burden i would feel
leaving my shoulders like my heart
expanding
hugging my kids hugging my wife and all
of a sudden yeah man i think everything
would taste different
i think the the things that i think are
important
like catching the latest netflix show or
making sure all my emails are answered
or the
the lawn's gonna be murdered i mean the
lawn's gotta be mowed perfectly i think
all that nonsense
right would go out the window right i
think i'd probably be a lot more
optimistic a lot more interested in
looking people in the eye and asking
them how they're doing and
making sure people felt loved and
connected and
making sure that i was doing what i was
passionate about and what i felt i could
contribute to my neighborhood and to my
family
and to my country and so how do i best
communicate to my family and friends
this is me now jesus i'm just wrestling
with this in my own mind right now
i think first and foremost you're gonna
best communicate this
through eye contact through smiles
through generosity
through handshakes through post-covet
hugs if we ever get to do those again
i think it's going to be less about
communicating in words and more about
demonstrating an action let them see
the new generous jesus let them get to
know the guy who doesn't lose his temper
as much anymore
who shows up to help on saturdays and
sundays and mondays before work
the guy who shows up after hours to help
move people's couch
the guy who loans them their truck
without even thinking about it because
it's just a
piece of metal on four rubber tires
right
i think you best communicate by living
differently
and if you've got some folks that you
hurt in the past jesus or that you are
short with or angry with or that knew
you as this
rough and tough dude and i'm just making
this up because this isn't written here
but
i think it'd be a gift to write them a
letter an actual handwritten letter on
paper with lines on it with a pen
and just say hey you know what old jesus
was a jerk and for whatever reason
the god of the universe is giving me
round two giving me a second chance and
i'm not gonna blow it
and part of not blowing it is making
amends for who i was before
and i know that this is just words i
know this is just me writing notes
and you have to watch me live
differently but i want you to know that
i'm a different guy
and i'm going to demonstrate that every
minute of every day for the rest of my
life that's how i'd handle it
um the most important thing is that we
remember that
people don't listen to us they watch us
that's what communicates what what
what matters to us that's what
communicates what we're about
is how we treat people man so jesus man
congratulations brother
on a second chance at life
don't squander it and make sure
that you love those people close to you
i want to end today with a song of the
day
something we do every time on the john
de loni show
um the dr john delonay show is it is we
reach back into some songs that were
important to me as a kid that are
important to me
now that may be important to you too so
shoot me an email at ask
john ramseysolutions.com if you have a
song that you'd like me to
read some lyrics to today's song of the
day
comes from the classic probably one of
the best albums
ever recorded by one of the greatest
bands who ever lived
and some people say i love the beatles
or i love jay-z wrong
all of you wrong the greatest band of
all time is poison
and one of their seminal records is
flesh and blood back in the 90s
and this the lyrics are from the song
something to believe in
and it goes like this i drive by the
homeless sleeping on a cold dark street
like
bodies in an open grave and underneath a
broken old neon sign that used to read
jesus saves
a mile away live the rich folks and i
see how they're living it up
and while the poor they eat from hand to
mouth the rich is drinking from a golden
cup
and it just makes me wonder why so many
lose
and so few win just give me something
to believe in just give me something to
believe in
if i had a lighter i would be holding it
up the folks in the booth are holding up
the lighters
give me something to believe in good
folks it's been awesome being with you
today this
is the dr john deloney's show
[Music]
you